we have some very interesting new
polling from these early days of the joe
biden administration
and 69 percent of americans approve
of joe biden's week one coveted response
and if you know anything about the
hyper partisan and politicized divided
nature of the united states 69 percent
of americans agreeing about anything is
uh pretty remarkable and there are even
better numbers than that this is an abc
news
ipsos poll released yesterday 69 percent
of americans
support joe biden's covid 19 response
thus far
that's 97 of democrats
70 of independents but very
interestingly
almost half of republicans 40 percent of
republicans
approve of the way joe biden so far
has handled coronavirus now in
comparison
the highest approval rate that trump
ever had
on the pandemic was 55
but when was it it was mid-march what
had trump done in mid-march i think it
was march 12th or 15th
that trump said we're shutting down
travel from china or europe
that was his high point of 55 percent
and it's only been down from there
joe biden already at 69
approval on coronavirus what has he done
so far that people approve of well on
day one he did sign the executive orders
he promised to sign
the federal face mask mandate at federal
buildings and on transportation et
cetera
he also uh put together a number of
other specific plans which are yet to be
voted on
um in terms of coronavirus stimulus
vaccine distribution
and much much more interestingly the
mask mandate
has 81 support across the country 81
support and joe biden also importantly
stopped
the american withdrawal from the world
health organization
immediately putting dr anthony fauci as
the sort of liaison or spokesperson for
the u.s
in the rekindled relationship with the
w.h.o
70 percent of americans also agree with
getting back into
or halting our exit from the w-h-o
this is a really really big deal
and the reason it's a big deal is that
again in this country it's really hard
to get
numbers that high on anything if you you
know we've talked before on presidential
approval
you have probably 20 percent of the
country who will never abandon the
president and 20 percent of the country
that will never approve of the job the
president's doing meaning
even though on paper a president's
approval could be between zero and 100
it's really probably between 20 and 80.
and
um when we look at the data
over recent times about do you think
trump really won the election the people
who thought even up until january 20th
and maybe still today
that somehow trump is going to get a
second term 30
of this country seems basically cuckoo
for coco puffs and i know some people
won't like that phrase but what i mean
is
there is a non-trivial portion of this
country 25
30 percent maybe that includes that 20
that will never abandon trump
plus another 5 to 10 percent that thinks
they are
evaluating the situation and coming to
those same conclusions
that is completely disconnected from
reality
completely disconnected from from
empiricism and facts
and thinking and rationality and so when
you see
wow in a country where 25 or 30 percent
of the country is whacked
81 percent approval on a mask mandate
that really tells you something these
are numbers that are
in practice effectively as close to
unanimity as you can expect to get in a
country that says ideologically
call it diverse as the united states
we also have from this new poll this abc
news
ipsos poll the question of do you
believe
joe biden will unite the country now at
the top of the show i said no we're
what i see regardless of joe biden's
efforts
i don't believe that we will see a
united united states
in any true sense 57 percent of
respondents believe that joe biden will
make
progress in uniting the country not
a great number but it's something and
we will continue to track all of this
data we are starting to see
cases now as i predicted months ago this
isn't because of anything joe biden did
yet
we are starting to see cases come down
from their pandemic high
around january 10th and hopefully they
will continue on down
hopefully deaths will turn the corner
hospitalizations in many areas are
already going down so
let's hope that we continue in this
direction under joe biden
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing and
magic spoon now lets you create your own
customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100 percent of your money
if you don't love it no questions asked
go to magicspoon.com
pacman to build your own custom variety
box today
make sure to use promo code pacman to
get free shipping
the link is right underneath this video